hey guys I saw the new Star Trek movie
already jealous I'm not sure if it's
better than the first one what I'm
having that debate in my head it's right
there to blast
since we're all about Star Trek today we
brought in an awesome panel to talk Trek
down on the end from NPR's marketplace a
stereoscope knows guys a very funny
writer performer from The Upright
Citizens Brigade theater Kevin Pietersen
hello and an actor who you may have seen
in idiocracy community Michael McCaffrey
so guys Star Trek is clearly popular JJ
Abrams brought it back let's talk next
generation reboot who do we want to see
play these iconic characters got to
start with the Captain jean-luc Picard
who would we want to see playing I would
want Breaking Bad's Bryan Cranston if
diplomacy fails he'll murder you and
everything you love you got like Walter
White who'd be like come on Romulans
let's see if we can figure something out
of here and then if that doesn't work
you've got Heisenberg Bryan Cranston for
everyone in Star Trek The Next
Generation you would watch that show you
know you would that III think that could
be like a new race of aliens or
something the crazed Aransas he would be
my pick I see Cranston but I'll raise
you a huge Ackman there's a side of a
card that's very uh theatrical Hugh
Jackman brings you that and then on top
of that he's worked with Patrick Stewart
in the x-men movies so I like to think
that Patrick Stewart would give him his
blessing oh wow you really gave that a
lot of thought I mean I think Hugh
Jackman is a terrible choice for Picard
but um you did put a lot of thought into
that so a point for that I'm gonna go uh
go for jean-luc Picard being French Jean
Dujardin from the artist can that guy
even speak English enough to carry an
episode doesn't matter that will dub
them all over it will double review
Jackman I got to go with Cranston
commander Riker I'm gonna say Matthew
McConaughey attractive not necessarily
that's smart if you put him in command
you're gonna be a little scared he's
doing some good acting lately and he'd
be a fun Riker that'd be weird for Riker
be played by a good actor though I mean
well for me it's Bradley Cooper you can
see why somebody thinks he might want to
be captain but he really shouldn't be
captain and also I think he can rock the
beard if he needed to if you want
someone we know could pull off solid
beard Robb Stark from Game of Thrones
the actor's name is a Richard Madden
yeah you know it's an all-or-nothing
deal with Riker if you don't get that
beard the whole franchise falls
let's talk Wharf Michael what do you say
Quinton Rampage Jackson I want a guy
who's gonna kick your ass like in real
life
stereos uh for my Wharf I'd go with
Terry Crews I think that like Worf is
inherently a funny character I think
Terry Crews is like a giant jack guy who
you would be scared of but he's also
really funny uh he's very funny I'm
gonna give you Terry Crews I'm gonna
give it to you I'm racking my points
here I really like Terry Crews
Lieutenant Commander data what are we
thinking a stereo uh I'm lieutenant
metadata I've picked Tom Cruise data is
someone who really really wants to look
human and act human but just can't and
this this has Tom Cruise all over it and
then also they both have a lot of
experience fighting aliens we're talking
drink ass not a bad choice Kevin I'm
gonna go with Haley Joel Osment he's
still acting well he'll be data if they
ever want to get y'all to choose some
scenery bring in lore data's evil
brother and lacked a little pool
personally I thought a solid choice
might be Joseph gordon-levitt what's
gonna put butts in seats an actor the
truth doing it or an actor that
shouldn't be doing or the comeback kid
Geordi LaForge I'm gonna go with Donald
Faison you know what is with his work on
scrubs in the high high stress world of
dealing with Zach Braff yeah that's a
full-time job
yeah you know I think that he that he
would be able to bring that sort of
don't talk to me anger that that Geordi
kind of has simmering under his surface
I think a realistic choice uh Donald
Glover a cake wrapper childish gambino
really fun to watch I'll give you the
word Donald moving on fellas counselor
Troi
we gotta have someone some gravitas I'm
just gonna go for Judi Dench I'm gonna
give you a Marion Cotillard for a
council Tori I would want Penelope Cruz
from 1994 your choice more than anything
was dictated by your puberty fantasy yes
I think there were a lot of crushes in
the Troy until seven of nine usurped her
dr. Beverly Crusher said Juliet from
lost the actresses name is Elizabeth
Mitchell she plays a doctor yeah unlost
and I like her on TV she does sci-fi
shows know what I don't think loss to
Star Trek is that huge a leap uh Michael
well yeah as I went over for the
counselor middle younger I'm gonna say
scholar Johansson to get that sex appeal
so interesting choices but going with
the redhead keeping it ginger I gotta
say Christina Hendricks oh oh
Oh feels let's keep it whoopee
well people whoopee yeah I want to thank
my panel you guys are awesome and you
put a lot of thought too much thought
into this topic thanks for being here
so with JJ Abrams doing Star Trek on
board for Star Wars what TV show or
movie franchise should eat reboot next
leave the answer in the comment section
below also tell us your dream cast for
that project best answer gets screen
junkies t-shirt I'm Hal Rudnick thanks
for watching
bye bye hey guys feel like demon out
energize